it's 5-star luxury like London has never
seen this is shangri-la's first foray
into the UK and the Capitals only
high-rise hotel the lowest room is about
130 meters in the air and then the
highest room is going to be almost 100
and meet 80 metres in the air the
projects a year behind schedule and
ended up costing more than 67 million
dollars it's been a challenging but
ultimately necessary process for the
Hong Kong based company we are moving
into different areas you know
traditionally we are an Asian based
hotel company we're very proud of that
but coming to a city like London it
increases our global appeal in a
business where first impressions count
this is a lasting one for to ceiling
windows in every room make sure you
never forget where you are perched high
above London skyline we're very excited
about the gold bar which will be at the
top of the hotel section here in the
shard as far as we know it's the highest
bar in Western Europe views like this
you'll have to pay for rooms start at
seven hundred and sixty dollars a night
with the best Suites topping five and a
half grand not for those weary of
heights
Angus Bennett Bloomberg